el alcalde de Munich yo el tradicional
golpe de Martillo al primer túnel de
cerveza marcando el inicio del
octoberfest decenas de miles de personas
se reunieron en la capital bávara
esperando tener un sitio en las carpas
instaladas por la ocasión
me hacía mucha ilusión cuando estás allí
tienes la misma sensación de hace tres
años y sigues queriendo participar tengo
la duda de si cabemos en una carpa la
última vez también nos quedamos fuera no
es lo mejor pero ya veremos
se espera que así están unas 5 millones
de personas hasta el 3 de octubre no hay
nada igual el espíritu todo el mundo
está muy emocionado de estar aquí no hay
nada en el mundo que sea como esto la
energía el festival de la cerveza fue
congelado dos años seguidos por el covid
19 los bávaros esperaban su reanudación
con mucha impaciencia
estoy muy contento Yo también he hecho
mucha campaña para que se celebre
necesitamos alegría sobrevivir
necesitamos tradición y necesitamos
apoyo la producción de cerveza es un
culto nacional en Alemania especialmente
en bavaria el primer octoberfest se
celebró en 1810 y este año marca la
edición número 187 del evento